mr. McCall yeah sorry man we're looking  into a homicide it occurred two weeks  ago five dead Russian restaurant oh yeah  I heard about no TV I happen to be there  that night are you yeah you wouldn't be  here if I wouldn't that's right  we're just checking to see if any of the  patrons remembered anything suspicious  that thing not that I recall  may I ask why are you dying that that  particular restaurant like Borowski  didn't stay long I didn't check my watch  I see well thanks for your cooperation  I'll be in touch don't you want to leave  me your card officer okay so I remember  anything that's what you policeman  usually doing must have given them all  out how'd you find me  I paid cash we didn't have a reservation  how'd you find me Wow that's what we do  mr. McCall we have find people he need  fine  Weehoo